the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right get started today's all about
Lagrange will method we will talk a lot
about what we really mean by generalized
coordinates and generalized forces and
then do a number of application examples
there's a set of notes on stellar on the
Lagrangian it's about 10 pages long and
I highly recommend you you read them
they're there they're not somehow up
with the notes associated with lecture
notes or 10 I'm going to way down at the
bottom so you have to scroll all the way
down in the stellar website to find them
the there's our second quiz is November
8th that's a week from next Tuesday ok
pretty much same format as the first one
ok so let's talk about how to use
Lagrange equations
so I defined what's called the
Lagrangian last time t minus V the
kinetic energy minus the potential
energy of the entire system total
kinetic and total potential energy
expressions then we have some quantities
Q J's these are defined as the
generalized forces generalized dis
coordinates I should say and the capital
Q sub J's are the generalized forces and
the Lagrange equation says that D by DT
the time derivative of the partial of L
with respect to the Q J dots the
velocities - the parsh minus the partial
derivative of L with respect to the
generalized displacements equals the
generalized forces and in for typical
system you'll have a number of degrees
of freedom like say 3 and if you have
three degrees of freedom you need three
equations of motion and so that your the
J's will go from 1 to 3 in that case so
the J's here refer to an indicee that
gives you the number of equations that
you need so you do this calculation for
coordinate 1 again for according to
again four coordinate three and you get
then three equations of motion ok so
this is a little a little obscure I like
to let's just plug in
for L equals t minus B and just put it
in here and see what happens you get D
by DT of the partial of T with respect
to Q J dot minus D by DT of the partial
of V with respect to Q J dot plus
organized this way - the partial of T
with respect to Q J plus the partial of
V with respect to Q J equals capital Q J
now when we first talked about potential
energy in a few days ago we said that
for mechanical systems the potential
energy is not a function of time or
anybody remember velocity so the
potential energy is not a function of
time velocity what will happen to this
term because it just goes away so this
is zero for mechanical systems you know
if you start getting into electrons
moving in magnetic fields then you start
having potential energies involving
velocities but for mechanical systems
this term zero and I think the
bookkeeping though so this is the form
of lagrangians that I write down when
I'm doing problems I don't write this
mathematicians like you know elegance
and this comes down to this beautifully
elegant simple looking formula but I'm
an engineer and I like it to be
efficient you know and prayer and
practically useful this is the
practically useful form of Lagrange
equations so you just use what you need
then tension etic energy here kinetic
energy their potential energy there and
I number these there's a lot of
bookkeeping in LaGrange so I call that
term one term to term three and term
four because you have to grind through
this quite a few times and so when you
do basically you take one the results of
one plus two plus three equals four and
you do that J times to get the equations
you're after
okay so a little now we need to talk a
little bit about what we mean by
generalized coordinates QJ general
already you know what's this word
generalized mean generalized just means
it doesn't have to be Cartesian not
necessarily Cartesian as in X Y Z a lot
of Liberty and how you choose
coordinates not necessarily Cartesian
not even inertial they do have to
satisfy certain requirements the
coordinates they must be what we call
independent
they must be complete and must be
independent and complete and the system
must be holo nomic now get to that in a
minute so we need to you need to
understand what it means to be
independent complete and holonomic
so what I mean by independent so if you
have a multiple degree of freedom system
and you fix all but one of the
coordinates to see system can't move in
in all but one of its coordinates that
last degree of freedom still has to have
a complete range of motion so if you
have a double pendulum and you grab the
first mass the second mass can still
move it takes two angles to define your
double pendulum so independent when you
fix all but one coordinate still have a
continuous range of movement and
essentially in the free coordinate and
that's independence and we'll just we'll
just kind of use it what you will do
this by example mostly and complete the
complete really means that's capable of
locating all parts of the system at all
times
okay
so let's think about let's look at the
system here double pendulum two simple
one just made out of two particles and
strings I sure didn't bring one today
and I could I need to pick some
coordinates to describe this okay and
we'll put this in a we'll use some
Cartesian coordinates here so and x and
a y and there's particle one and I could
choose to describe this system core X Y
coordinates and I'll specify the
location the system with coordinates
x-one and y-one two values to specify
the location of that and I'm down here
I'm going to pick two more values X 2
and Y 2 just to describe the so these
are X 1 is a different coordinate from X
2 X 1 is the x position of particle 1 X
2 is the x position of particle 2 y 1
and y 2 okay so how many coordinates do
I have to describe the system how many
up I used four right how many degrees of
freedom do you think this problem has
two right so it's something already a
little out of whack here okay but the
point is these aren't independent you'll
find you just do a test find that these
aren't independent if I fix x1 and x2
systems doesn't move right I say this is
got to be one and this is got to be
three the it the system is now frozen so
this system of core coordinates is not
independent it would say independent
when you fix all but one coordinate it
still have continuous range of movement
of the final one I can fix only just two
of these and I've frozen the system I
don't even have to go to the extent of
fix and three I'm assuming the strings
are of fixed length you can't change the
string length okay so this is not a very
good choice coordinate so we didn't had
a hint that it might not because it's
more than we oughta use we only really
need two okay so and then if we choose
these angles v1 and v2 let's do the test
with that are those independent so those
are the coordinates of the system if you
fix v1 it's there still free and
continuous movement of v2 of the system
sure and if you fix the two means you
can require this angle stay rigid like
that and move v1 while the whole system
will still move so v1 and v2 are a
system which satisfies the independence
requirement complete they're both
systems are complete they're both
capable locating all points at all times
okay but only the pair v1 and v2 in this
example are both independent and
complete now the third requirement is
thanks thing called Hollen holo no miss
city and what hold on what it means to
be holonomic is that the system the
number of degrees of freedom required is
equal to the number of recordin 'its
required to completely describe the
motion now most of the time every
example we've ever done so far in this
class
satisfies that we pick v1 and v2 and
that's all the coordinates we need to
completely describe the motion let me
see if I can figure out a counter
example so I did I didn't write down
this definition so holonomic
and if the answer to this question is no
you cannot use Lagrange equations so
let's see if show you an example of a
system in which you need more
coordinates than you have degrees of
freedom I've got a ball it's on the X
this is an X Y plane and I'm not going
to allow it to translate in Z and I'm
not going to allow it to rotate about
the z axis so I'm construe to
constraints right so this is one rigid
body I mean how many general how many
degrees of freedom does it have six okay
I'm going to constrain it so no Z motion
five no Z rotation four I'm not it's not
going to allow it to slip this is X and
that's why I'm not going to allow it to
slip in the X so now I've got another
that's one round down to three and I'm
not going to allow it to slip in the Y 2
so that by our calculus of how many
degrees of freedom you need we're down
to two we should be able to describe
completely describe the motion of this
system with two coordinates okay so I've
got this put this piece of tape on the
top and it's pointing diagonally that
way and I'm going to roll this ball like
this until it shows up again so it's
right on top just the way it started
okay now start off the same way again
I'm going to roll first this way and
then I'm going to roll this way to the
same place where is the stripe in the
back so I've gone to the same position
but I've ended up with the ball not in
the same orientation as it was and went
by two different paths and the ball
comes out over here rather than up there
where it started okay so this system
actually to actually describe where the
ball is at any place out here having
gotten there by running around rolling
around without slipping and without
z-rotation
how many coordinates do you think it
will take to actually specify where that
stripe is are at any arbitrary place
that it's gotten to on the plane name-o
so you got in order to actually fully
describe it you got to say where it is
X&Y and you actually have to say some
kind of theta and fee rotations that
it's gone through so that you know where
this is okay so this system is not whole
anomic and whole anomic it has to be
holonomic in order to be in order to use
LaGrant equations so when you go to do
LaGrant problems you need to test for as
your coordinates complete independent
and holonomic and you get pretty good at
it
so
so here's my lagrangian's and I have
itemized these for calculate
calculations you have to do column one
two three and four and so what I just
want when I want to write out is just to
show you it's just to get you to adapt a
systematic approach to doing the garage
so left hand side so the left hand side
of your equations of motion is
everything with T and B the right hand
side is has these generalized forces so
you have to deal with and generalized
forces are the non conservative forces
in the system okay so this is going to
get a little bit cookbook but it's I
think you appropriate for the moment
here so step one determine the number of
degrees of freedom that you need and
choose your Delta J's those are your
Delta excuse me just cute J's choose
your coordinates you find the number of
degrees of freedom and choose the
coordinates you're going to use
basically
verify complete independent polo knowing
three compute T and V for every rigid
body in the system compute your kinetic
and potential energies one two three
four each QJ so for every coordinate you
have you have to go through these
computations one two three four four
every coordinate and this is your left
hand side and if you don't have any
external forces any non conservative
external forces then 1 2 1 plus 2 Plus 3
equals zero but if you have non
conservative forces then you have to
compute the right-hand side
so the right-hand side so for each QJ
each generalized coordinate you need to
find the generalized force that gently
goes with it
and you do this by computing the virtual
work Delta W I'll put the allele NC up
here to remind you these are for the
non-conservative forces the Delta W
associated with the virtual displacement
Delta QJ so for every generalized
Courtney have you're going to try out
this little Delta Q Delta of motion in
that coordinate and figure out how much
virtual work you've done so so Delta WJ
is going to be Q J Delta J so whatever
this is the thing you're looking for and
it's going to be a function of all those
external non-conservative forces acting
through a little virtual displacement a
little bit of work will be done mostly
I'm going to teach you how to do this
fight by example
so let's quickly do a really simple
trivial system our mass spring dashpot
system single degree freedom M K B it's
going to take one coordinate to describe
the motion X happens to be Cartesian
there'll be one generalized coordinate
so Q J equals Q 1 equals Q X in this
case it's our x coordinate actually I
should just call it X that's our
generalized coordinate for this problem
is it complete yep is it independent yes
is it whole anomic no problem ok we need
t 1/2 M X dot squared we need V and we
have 1/2 K x squared for the spring plus
minus MGX for the gravitational
potential energy and now we can start
and we have some external
non-conservative forces what are they
fi non conservative and I think I'll
better I'm going to put an excitation on
here to sum F of T so what are the non
conservative forces
Jonathon pardon
it's not K but oh it my mistake sorry
about the you're correct I'm just my
brain is getting a head at my writing
here that's normally B and this would be
K I'm not trying to really mess you up
there so what would that it would be BX
dot right okay right and is there
anything else are there any other non
conservative forces things that could
put energy into or out of the system so
the damper can certainly extract energy
yeah the force F that external it might
be you know something is making it
vibrate or whatever but it's an external
force so they could do work on the
system and it's not necessarily a it's
not a potential it's not a spring and
it's not a high gravity it's coming up
in somebody shaking it or something like
that so f is also non conservative so
the non conservative forces in this
thing are F in the I direction and minus
BX dot in the I direction and we could
in our normal approach using Newton we
draw a Freebody diagram and we add that
we identify a BX dot on it and an F on
it but we'd also have our K X on it that
would be what a Freebody diagram would
look like and the non that's a
conservative force oops and we need an
mg so a two conservative force is KX and
mg and we have two non conservative
forces BX dot and F so in this case the
non can some of the non conservative
forces is the F in the I direction minus
BX in the I X dot in the I direction so
let's do our calculus here so one D by
DT of the partial of T which is one-half
M X dot squared with respect to X dot
that gives me the derivative of X dot
squared respect to X dot gives me a to
MX dot so this is D by DT of M X dot but
that's M X double dot and as you might
expect when you're trying to drive
equation of motion you're probably going
to end up with n MX double dot in the
result and it always comes out of these
D by DT expressions okay so that's term
one term - in this problem - T with
respect to X in this case is T a
function of X so one half MX dot squared
but it so is T a function of
displacement X it's a function of
velocity in the X direction but is it a
function of displacement no so this term
is zero three our third term partial of
V with respect to X well where is V half
KX squared the derivative of this is KX
minus mg okay and we sum those so we get
MX double dot plus
okay X minus mg equals on the right-hand
side this is for now we need to do four
for the right-hand side and four is
really the summation of the F is the
individual forces dotted with D are
these are both vectors D R is the
movement a little bit of work and it's
going to be a delta quantity like Delta
X and F of the applied forces and you
need to sum these up so this D are in
general is going to be a function of the
Delta J's the virtual displacements in
all the possible degrees of freedom of
the system we do them one at a time this
case we only have one so it's trivial
but this could be you know Delta one two
three four and each one of them might do
some work when F moves through it but
work is f dot the displacement so it's
the component of the force in the
direction of the movement the dot
product that gives you this little bit
of virtual work okay so in this problem
this is going to be equal to we actually
have an F of T some function of time in
the I Direction minus be X dot in the I
Direction dotted with Delta X which is
our virtual displacement in our single
generalized coordinate and this whole
thing is going to be equal to Q X Delta
X
so you figure out the virtual work
that's done so Delta so if you do this
dot product this is also in the I hat
direction so i dot i i dot i just get
ones because the forces are in the same
direction as that is as the displacement
you're going to get an F T F of T Delta
X is one of the little bits of virtual
work and you'll get a minus BX dot Delta
X and that together those two pieces
added together are the generalized force
times Delta X this total here gives you
Delta W non-conservative for in this
case coordinate X so we need trying to
solve for what goes on the right-hand
side we need the Q X so we have here you
notice what'll happen you'll divide
it'll cancel out the Delta X's that
result and in this case what you're left
with is Q X equals F of t minus B X dot
so this is number four so Q X Delta X is
a bit of virtual work that's done what
goes into our equation of motion is the
QX part and we got it by computing the
virtual work done by the applied
external non-conservative forces as we
imagine them going through Delta X and
we're done you have the complete
equation of motion for a single degree
of freedom system you could rearrange it
a little bit MX double dot plus BX dot
plus KX equals mg plus f of T if you
will so it's the same thing you would
have gotten from saying from using
Newton in a you know trivial kind of
exam
but it helps define each of the steps
things that we said we're required okay
so we're going to go from there to a
much harder problem so any issues or
questions about definitions procedure so
we start getting into multiple degrees
of freedom you need is set up a careful
bookkeeping so I I just do this myself
that nice top of the page I identify my
coordinates right write down T write
down V then I say okay coordinate 1 1 2
3 4 equation then I start the coordinate
to calculus 4 1 2 3 & 4 and so forth
till you get to the end ok questions
yeah
all right these are functions of the of
the Delta J's this debt this D are where
it comes from the work that's being done
in the virtual displacement around a
dynamic equilibrium position for the
system is a little movement of the
system dr and we express it it's
expressed in terms of the generalized a
virtual displacement of the generalized
coordinates of the system so where the
dr comes from is going to be delta in
this case it's only delta x and in the
next problem we're going to do the force
in the problem is not in exactly the
same direction as the Delta X's and
Delta Theta s and so forth so when you
do the dot product only that component
of the force that's in the direction of
the virtual displacement e does work and
you account for that so let's let's look
into it more difficult problem so the
problem is this I tried to I tried to
fix this up before I came to class and I
really didn't really quite have the the
parts and pieces I needed but this is a
piece of just a piece of steel pipe here
the sleeve on the outside of this rod
and I've got a spring that's on the
outside connected to this piece and so
it can do this okay
and it's also though a pendulum so the
system I really want to look at is this
system so this swings back and forth to
think slides up and down so this has
multiple sources of kinetic energy
multiple forms of Kappa tential energy
okay and all for the purpose of the
problem I'm going to say that there's a
force that's always horizontal
acting on this mass pushing the system
back and forth some F cosine Omega T
always horizontal and I want to drive
the equations of motion of the system so
is it a planar motion problem all right
how many rigid bodies involved okay
so in you know four so there's two
there's two rigid bodies each could have
possibly six degrees of freedom but when
you say it's a planar motion you're
actually immediately confining each
rigid body to three each rigid body can
move x and y and rotate and z so the
number when you write out and out say
this is planar motion you've just said
each rigid body has max three so this
has a maximum of six possible right no
the other one other three disappeared
too is no Z deflection and no rotation
in the X or Y okay so we have a possible
possible maximum six how many degrees of
freedom does this problem have how many
coordinates will we need to completely
describe the motion of the system so
come up so think about that talk to a
neighbor decide on the coordinates that
we need to use for the system while I'm
drawing it
okay what do you decide how many -
alright what would you recommend what
would you choose pardon an angle and a
deflection of what I'm calling em - here
okay so this is M - rod is M one and
he's suggesting an angle theta and a
deflection which I'll call X 1 and I've
attached to this bar the rod I'm calling
it a rotating coordinate system x1 y1
about point a so a x1 y1 is my rotating
coordinate system attached to this rod
ok so I'm going to locate the position
of this by some value x1 measured from
point a and locate the position of the
rod itself by an angle theta good is it
complete so if you freeze one you still
have that complete is a kenda to
describe the motion at any possible
position those two things yes is it
independent if you freeze X can theta
still move three static and the X still
move okay is it whole element right to
equals you know you need two we got two
and they're independent and complete
good now the harder work starts so I'm
going to give us the mass of the rod the
mass moment of inertia of the rod about
the z axis but with respect to a the
length of the rod is l1 the sleeve mass
m2 G i ZZ with respect to its G so it
has a G there's also an I better call it
G -
that's the G of the sleeve there's also
a g1 a center of mass for the rod and a
center of mass for the sleeve those are
properties we'll need to know and I'll
give them to you okay so we need to come
up with expressions for potential energy
and kinetic energy so but this this
problem the kinetic potential energy is
a little messy because you have to pick
references you have to account for the
unstretched length of the spring all
right so call L 0 is the un-- stretched
spring length give it a we know that
also so I proposed that the potential
energy look like 1/2 for the spring
anyway 1/2 the amount that it stretches
in a movement x1 the amount that it
stretches then should be whatever that
x1 position is and that x1 position and
I have just drew it slightly incorrectly
I'm going to use x1 to locate the center
of mass which is always a good practice
so here's the center of mass so my x1
goes to the center of mass okay that's
x1 so that's the that's the total
distance and you from that we need to
subtract l0 the unstretched length of
the spring and we need to subtract half
the length of the body because it's
going that that's that extra bit here ok
so this is the amount that the string is
actually stretched when you go through a
motion when there's most one did it
coordinate is x1 and you got to square
that and that'll be the kinetic excuse
me the potential energy
stored in the spring and then we got to
do the same thing for the potential
energy you have two sources of potential
energy and they and due to gravity and
they are two objects right to potential
energy so why don't you take a minute
and tell me the potential energy
associated with the rod so the rod has a
center of mass and the center of it's a
pendulum basically so it's the same as
all the pendulum problems you've ever
seen and I would recommend that we use
as our reference position it's static
equal its equilibrium position hang
straight down and I'm going to I'll tell
you in advance I'm going to use the
unstretched spring position this time
I'd just stay with that that's where
it's going to start from that's my
reference for potential energy but does
this does this is the unstretched spring
position to have anything to do with the
potential energy of the rod no okay so
it's reference position it's just
hanging straight down so figure it out
what's giving a potential energy
expression for just the rod part think
about that
so I'm going to remind you about
something about potential energy
potential energy one of the requirements
about it is the change of potential
energy from one position to another is
path independent so you don't actually
ever have to do the integral of no minus
mg dot dr you know how to do the
integral you just have to account for
the change in height between its
starting position and its some other
position so spend a minute or two think
about that we're going to got a question
okay
and you talk talk to a neighbor check
your ideas and then
so you have a suggestion for me ladies
huh okay anybody want to make an
improvement on that or like they like it
improvement one minus cosine theta so
let's put that up and let's figure out
if we need that so could because we've
have a bid for cosine theta and one
minus cosine theta so you need to have a
potential energy at the reference and
you need to have a potential energy at
the final point and the difference
between the two is a change in potential
energy here okay so what's the reference
potential energy is mg L 1 over 2 when
it hangs straight down and then when it
moves up to this other position this is
the L 1 over 2 times this is Delta H
this is the change in height that it
goes through so you need the 1 minus
right and why is it and do we have the
signs right yeah
okay
so now we need another term and I'll
write this one down we need a little
this one's a little Messier we need a
potential energy term due to gravity for
the sleeve and that's going to mimic
this you're going to have a term here
plus m2g
and it's reference I'm just going to do
it as a reference amount minus the final
amount the reference will be at the
initial location of its center of mass
which is l0 plus L 2 over 2 minus m2g x1
cosine theta ok because this this one
gives a little Messier because you got
this thing it can move up and down the
sleeve and if that moves you've lost
your reference so you can't do this is
it concise little term like this you
have to separate out the reference and
then this is the final and the end the
l0 plus L 2 this quantity here is the
initial starting height this x1 cosine
theta is the finishing height and the
difference between the two gives you the
change in the potential energy so this
is your potential energy expression this
Plus this Plus these all right
so what about tea that a bill right it
kinetic energies generally easier you've
got to count for all the parts and
pieces so we have two chunks and we're
going to have rotational kinetic energy
associated with a rod rotational kinetic
energy associated with the sleeve will
all sell some translational kinetic
energy associated with the sleeve right
and I'll write these terms down I mean
I've made to make the problem go a
little faster here one half eyes easy
about a four that's the first that's the
rod plus a half eyes easy for the sleeve
about gee we'll discuss why the
difference here and that's theta dot
squared now for the kinetic energy that
comes from translation of the center of
mass because I'm broken up I've
accounted for this is a let me start
over
this system is pinned about a and and
the rod is just simply pinned today and
that the last lecture I put up these
different conditions and simplifications
you can account for a something about a
fixed pin by computing mass moment of
inertia about a it's basically a
parallel axis theorem argument times
one-half times that times theta dot
squared so this gives you all the
kinetic energy and one's go with the rod
but for the sliding mass because its
position is changing you can't do that
you have to account for the to come
on its of its but kinetic energy
separately this accounts for rotation
about G even though G's moving that
accounts for that energy this accounts
for because it's only a function of
theta dots not a function of that
position X this account this term is
going to account for then the kinetic
energy associated with the movement of
the center of mass so we need a vg2 in
the inertial frame dot vg2 okay these
pain vectors and does that get
everything I think that does so VGO
is it certainly has a component that is
its speed sliding up and down the rod
right and that's in the I hat direction
but it has another component due to what
it can tell me what it is is
contribution to its speed due to its
rotation
it's got to theta dot yep
it's kind of needs an R right yeah so
this would be an X 1-plus
no actually I made X one go right to the
so just X 1 theta dot in what direction
yeah so J hat here right the moving it's
actually that's the moving coordinate
system unit vector in the y direction
and so we do the dot to do the dot
product you get this times itself I dot
I and J dot J you get that this quantity
here is one-half m2 X dot squared plus X
this next one I guess x1 squared theta
dot squared that's the kinetic energy of
accounting for the velocity of the
center of mass so now we have an entire
kinetic energy expression
so now we have how many coordinates to
write how many times we have to turn the
crank and go through the Lagrangian
system yeah go through it twice so let's
apply the grunge here and we'll just do
number one first so and let's and let's
see which one do I have on my paper
first I guess we'll do the X one in
question this is Delta X 1 so this is
generalized coordinate X 1 and we need
to do term 1 which is then D by DT of
partial of T with respect to X 1 dot ok
so we look at this and say well we've
got to go is this a function is this
term a function of X of X nothing you
get nothing from there is this term a
function of X yeah it's down here so we
just this we only have to take the
derivative of this we have to do that
job ok so the derivative of this with
respect to X dot you get a 2 X dot here
do you get anything from here when you
do this with derivative respect to X dot
you only get a contribution from here
the two cancels that and so this should
look like m2 x1 dot but D by DT and I
won't do this do this once in two steps
here so you see where what happens you
get an m2 x1 double dot out of that ok
let's so we've gotten the first first
piece of this we've got a couple to go
but I want you you know a lot about
Newton's laws and you know a lot about
calculating equations of motion now
using some of torques and all that all
that stuff right so this is just
something moving has angular it's a
circular motion as translational motion
what other accelerations had better
appear in this equation of motion and
we're getting we you know which equation
are we getting there's going to be two
equations and answers physical
significance to it what's the equation
is beginning to look like just
physically what movement is being
accounted for here looks like
translation in the X direction it's this
thing sliding it's this part of the
motion sliding up and down there's
you're writing an equation of motion and
MX double dot has units of what torque
force this is a force equation this is
just F equals MA is whether this is what
this is going to show us remember the
direct method has to give you the same
answer as LaGrant so we're getting a
force equation it's describing MX double
dot what other what other acceleration
terms do you expect to appear in this
from what you know yeah a centripetal
term you believe there ought to be a
centripetal term in this answer why
because it's got circular motion
involved for sure any others is there
any Coriolis in this in this direction
which direction are we working in is
there Coriolis acceleration in the X
direction this by the way these
equations is do we have any ideas in
here these are pure scalar equations no
vector no unit vectors involved so this
equation only describe motion in the X
so will it be a Coriolis force in this
acceleration in this problem will there
be an or Larian acceleration in this
equation of motion the reason I'm going
through is
you I want you to start developing your
own intuition about whether or not when
you get the get it at the end it's got
everything or not to have and doesn't
have stuff it shouldn't have right okay
so the you're forecasting that we better
get a centripetal term well let's see
what happened so that was number one
number two here is our DT by minus DP
minus the derivative of the with respect
to X in this case so we go here x1 we've
been calling it is this a function of X
this piece nope is X dot how about this
one right take this derivative you get
2x so this fellow is going to give us
minus m2 x1 theta dot squared what's
that look like
there it is there's just a triple term
you're expecting to get okay and step
three is plus partial of V with respect
to X right in this case with respect to
X and where's our potential energy
expression well it's up here and where
are the X dependencies in it there is no
X in that term and no X in that term but
we have X's in both of these other terms
right so when we grind through this I'll
write down what we come up with we get
it certainly a spring term K x1 minus l0
minus l2 over 2 so that's the spring
piece when you take the derivative the
two cancels the 1/2 and the derivative
of parts inside just gives you 1 so that
it's the first piece of the potential
energy expression and the second piece
is only going to come from here the
derivative of this respect to x1 is just
mg m2 G cosine theta minus and you add
those bits together you end up with m2
x1 double dot minus m2 x1 theta dot
squared plus K x1 minus l0 minus l2 over
2 minus m2 G cosine theta so those are
the three terms one plus two plus three
that go on the left-hand side and
they're going to equal my Q X that I
find I still now have to find what the
generalized force is in the X direction
so it's always left to do for this
problem is to find Q sub X the
generalized force there goes on the
right hand side so now let's draw a
little little diagram here of my system
and at the end of the sleeve so here's
my sleeve I've applied this force this
is f of T maybe at some F naught cosine
Omega T it's an oscillatory force
external force make it vibrate and I
need to know the virtual work done
making that force go through a
displacement in what direction so this
equation is the x1 equation right and so
the virtual displacement I'm talking
about is Delta x1 and the amount of work
that it does is Delta x1 times the
component of this force that's in its
direction so I'm going to take this
force and break it up into two
components and if this is my theta this
is also theta
so this will be F not I'll leave out the
cosine Omega T here function of time but
this side then is cosine theta I know
hey I get this wrong I would drew this
wrong I'm sorry this is theta this is
going to be sine this side is sine theta
in the I direction and this piece is f
naught of T cosine theta in the J so I
break it up to parts and the virtual
work associated with x1 is the thing I'm
looking for
QX dotted with Delta x1 and that is f of
T here the vector dotted with D are my
little displacement but in this case
this then all works out to be F naught
cosine Omega T and it has sine theta I
plus Coast beta J components dotted with
Delta X in the I so you're only going to
get I J gives you 0 I dot I gives you 1
so you're going to get one piece out of
this it says then the QX equals F naught
cosine Omega T sine
theta and that's and this start with now
you have a delta X here and a delta X
here and that gives you the Delta
virtual work then to solve to find that
you need I need personally when I do
these problems I think in terms of that
little virtual deflection and I've
actually figure out what's the virtual
work done and then at the end I take
this out and this is the QX that I'm
looking for so my final equation of
motion says this equals F naught cosine
Omega T sine theta
that's your equation of motion in the x1
direction so when you watch it when you
finish one of these you need to ask
yourself does this make sense you know
does this jive with my understanding of
Newtonian physics better have a linear
acceleration term because that's what
it's doing
you have another acceleration term in
the same direction due to centripetal a
spring force for sure and a component of
gravity in the direction of motion down
this up and down the slide equal to any
external forces in that direction so it
makes pretty good sense okay
now also another test you can do is does
it satisfy the laws of statics and it's
another check you can perform this
what's does this thing at static you
Calibri and tell the truth at static
equilibrium all time derivatives are
zero so this would be 0 this would be 0
you know its static equilibrium hangs
down so cosine theta is 1 static you
don't have any time dependent forces
that's 0 so the static part of this says
that
since the K x1 minus l0 minus l2 over 2
equals m2 G cosine and that's cosine
theta is 1 so it's m2 G and you can
figure out then this must be K times
something this is the X this is the
amount that the spring stretches the
static stretch of the spring so that
it's equal to the spring has an equal
opposite force to the weight of the
thing m2 G so that's another check you
can do when doing the problems okay so I
want you just I'll write up the final
ant of the other one we have one more
equation to go right got to do all the
derivatives with respect to theta so do
you take a minute to decide oh how many
terms how many acceleration terms and
what acceleration terms do you expect to
see come out of this second equation of
motion because now we're talking about
which motion swinging motion and what's
its direction its you know in the
Newtonian sense it would have a vector
direction it's in the into what we call
J here okay so you're about to get the J
equation what X what terms do you expect
to find in it talk to your neighbors and
sort this out and tell me what the
basically tell me what the answer is
going to be
what do you think
what are we going to get
so it is a pendulum just a weird
pendulum so is there does this just the
theta change speed sure when it gets up
the top it swing at zero all the way
down its maximum speed so what term
sirico what term does that imply that
you're going to get it part well maybe
maybe not
yeah gonna get an early rain which means
you've got a fated double dot term
you're expecting a theta double dot term
to show up okay what else will you get a
Coriolis term do you expect two Coriolis
term something looks like X dot theta
dot yeah the thing is sliding up and
down the sleeve it has a nonzero value
of x dot anytime you got things moving
radially while something is swinging in
a circle you will get Coryell sources it
means the angular momentum of that thing
is changing and takes forces to make
that happen so here's what this answer
looks like
that's the one term the two-piece gives
you zero it's not a function of X in the
three-piece the potential energy piece
gives you m 2g x 1 sine theta plus M 1 G
L 1 over 2 sine theta and the fourth
piece the Q theta well that's just going
to be the virtual work done there is a
tricky bit to this one now there's
virtual work but which direction so we
have an F dot a D are the only F we have
is this
what's the D are what direction is it
this is the theta coordinate what
direction does that give you
displacements f dot dr is a displacement
not an angle to get the work done you
got to move a force through a distance
so the distance first of all is in what
direction when theta moves J little J
hat right and how much if now if you get
a virtual deflection of Delta Theta
what's the virtual displacement in a
virtual change in angle Delta Theta that
is that the virtual displacement
what's the displacement at this point
here in the J direction given a virtual
displacement Delta Theta think think
that out
can't quite hear x1 delta theta will
give you the motion the displacement at
the center of mass in that direction
x1 comes from here to here so x1 Delta
Theta will give you a little
displacement in that direction but is
that the Delta that is that the
displacement we care about we need to
displacement here so you're close so
we're going to get some force dot a
displacement dr and that's going to be
our force this guy with it's I and J
components on J terms but this term out
here is x1 plus l2 over to to get to the
N and it's in the J direction so it's a
length times a and and you need the
Delta this this quantity and you need a
delta theta Delta Theta this is the term
this is the dr for this system an angle
a virtual deflection and angle times the
moment arm gives you a distance it's in
the J hat Direction dotted with the same
force breaking the force up into its I
and J components it had a sine theta cos
theta J so this is going to give me a F
cosine Omega T cos theta J dot J
f naught cosine Omega T Coase beta X 1
plus L 2 over 2 Delta Theta is the Delta
W that's the work and the virtual the
generalized force Q theta is this part
of it so this Plus this Plus this equals
that on the right hand side so this is
part 4 so this is look at it yeah so f
of T you know I just I didn't want to
write it all out it this thing breaks
into an ion a J piece which is written
over there this is the sine theta i KO
stated J term which I pull that over to
brought back from over there and that
and we dot it with the dr that we care
about which is x 1 this length times
that angle in the j direction so j dot
we only pick up the j piece of this and
that gives us this cosine theta term
okay let's look quickly this is a
rotational thing it has units of that
force is this an equation a force
equation I theta double dot as units of
what torque it's a torque equation this
is the total mass moment of inertia is
easy with respect to a for the systems
that's at the oil arian acceleration the
torque it takes to make that happen is
the sum of the mass moment of inertia of
the rod plus the mass moment of inertia
of g plus m2 x1 squared which is looks a
lot like the parallel axis theorem this
is i ZZ a
or the moving mass there's your Coriolis
term
and here's your potential terms and
there's your external force okay talk
more about these things in recitation